and where are we
go Hello friends and welcome to Rotten
Tomatoes countdown as you've probably
seen around here we're pretty stoked to
be celebrating 25 years of Rotten
Tomatoes this year and because I love to
break the rules during a party we're
gonna throw our traditional countdown
format out the window but if I'm being
honest ranking 25 years of freshness
could take a while so instead these are
the top films from different categories
that we're using to break down the past
couple decades so grab your party hat
and let's celebrate the biggest and best
of rt25 right now on countdown
[Music]
most streamed a movie on Netflix red
notice
because this list is just so randomly
awesome this movie hit Netflix in
November 2021 and it picked up over 364
million hours of watch time in its first
28 days I mean that's a lot of butt
marks in people's couches but I mean it
was a post-pandemic world and you have
three huge stars in Dwayne Johnson Gal
Gadot and Ryan Reynolds plus all the
one-liners and action scenes to go with
them I mean what more do you need
foreign
this movie may not be fresh on the
Tomato Meter but the audience score for
red notice is way up there around 92
percent with a general feeling from
viewers that it delivers across the
board when it comes to big stars and
fast-paced action longest theatrical run
My Big Fat Greek Wedding
after a limited theatrical opening in
April of 2002 this romantic comedy
that's based on a one woman show just
kept on getting more and more popular
until it finally reached number two in
its 20th week and It ultimately lasted
308 straight days in theaters all hail
Tula it also became the highest grossing
rom-com ever in North America at the
time and ultimately spawned a franchise
that includes a series and a couple
sequels I mean number three is coming in
September and I just still love saying
that's okay I make lamb every time I
meet a vegetarian what's the problem am
I the best cook in the family oh I did
didn't I twice okay then
um
it's just uh
yeah
Ian is a vegetarian
he doesn't eat meat
you don't eat no meat no he doesn't eat
meat what do you mean he don't eat no
meat
oh that's okay that's okay I make lamb
come come
first movie to be certified fresh
Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless Mind
Rotten Tomatoes added a third level of
distinction between fresh and rotten in
late 2003 and thus this became the first
lucky film to earn the label of
certified fresh
alrighty then sorry wrong Jim Carrey
movie but speaking of he and Kate
Winslet Star as a couple who after a
painful breakup both undergo procedure
to erase memories of their former
partner and with that cool premise the
film picked up a best original
screenplay Oscar while Winslet was
nominated for best actress but really
it's her and Jim Carrey's chemistry and
serious acting chops that makes this one
worthy of this list and another watch
especially if you're going through a
breakup
my name is Clementine by the way I'm
Joel hi Joel
no jokes about my name oh no you
wouldn't do that you're trying to be
nice
I don't know any jokes about your name
Huckleberry Hound
I don't know what that means
are you nuts it's been suggested
Oh My Darling no My Darling
Clementine you were lost
no
most reviewed by critics Joker with
nearly 600 Critic reviews a number that
has continued to go up even this year
this fresh film brings a fresh take on
the character of Joker and the comic
book movie genre overall at the center
of that is of course an oscar-winning
performance from Joaquin Phoenix not to
mention bafta Critics Choice sag Golden
Globe and other Awards as a failed
comedian seeking connection and when it
comes down to it a little bit of decency
too
so that's it you're crazy that's your
defense for killing three young men
no
they couldn't carry a tune to save their
lives
oh why is everybody so upset about these
guys
if it was me dying on the sidewalk you'd
walk right over me I'd pass you every
day and you don't notice me but these
guys were because Thomas Wayne crying
about them on TV you have a problem with
Thomas Wayne yes I do
have you seen what it's like out there
Murray and with that many reviews I'm
sure you're dying to know how it was
critics consensized by us well they
called it quote a chillingly plausible
origin story that serves as a brilliant
showcase for its star there you go
preach it critics I mean I still can't
get joaquin's maniacal laugh out of my
head
first streaming film nominated for Best
Picture Manchester by the Sea this drama
film written and directed by Kenneth
Lonergan and starring Casey Affleck is
pretty heavy but man is it good so good
in fact that it was nominated for six
Academy Awards including best picture
making this Amazon bass flick the first
ever streaming option to earn that
nomination and by the way among those
six nominations were wins for best
original screenplay for Lonergan and
best actor for Affleck and seriously his
performance as a grief-stricken man is
gut-wrenchingly good
thank you
come away
[Music]
it's pretty much the role that made us
really wonder who is the better Affleck
brother you didn't expect me to answer
that did you I'll see you in the
comments for that one it's been though
obviously I mean have you seen air yet
most Oscar nominations La La Land This
film is nominated for an impressive 14
Academy Award nominations and one six
that includes best director for Damien
chazelle making him the youngest winner
in the category at the time at 32 years
old I mean geez I was 32 when I was
hosting some awesome shows on Rotten
Tomatoes oh wait La La Land also picked
up a Best Actress Oscar for Emma Stone
who starred alongside Ryan Gosling after
Emma Watson and Miles Teller both had to
drop out I mean imagine that and by the
way if they gave out Oscars for best
scenes with the keytar this movie
totally would have won for that too
foreign
[Music]
I mean the fact that shazelle shot a
full-on musical number on The
Interchange ramp in LA from the 110 to
the 105 deserves an Oscar alone some
might say it should have won best
picture too soon for the record
Moonlight should have totally won I'm
kidding most Oscar wins the Lord of the
Rings The Return of the King this film
won all 11 Academy Awards for which it
was nominated including best picture and
tied with Ben Hur and Titanic for the
most Oscar wins of all time not bad for
a fantasy Adventure film and I could get
all nerdy and tell you that this movie
contains almost 1500 visual effects
shots or that it joined the original
Star Wars Trilogy as the only film
series to win all best visual effects
Oscars or I could just show you a clip
of one of the epic battle scenes and
you'll totally get it
Feast on his flesh
I will kill you if you touch him to come
between
his prey
see I mean there's a reason the critics
call this one quote breathtaking and
emotionally powerful plus it grows over
one billion dollars at the worldwide box
office making it only the second film at
its time to achieve that honor and get
this post-production of the film wraps
so close to its release that director
Peter Jackson actually didn't get to see
the final theatrical version until its
official premiere
highest grossing film Avatar becoming
the first film to gross more than two
billion dollars at the worldwide box
office after its release in 2009. this
film still holds as the highest grossing
film ever for this one writer and
director James Cameron offered the lead
role of Jake Sully to stars like Matt
Damon and Chris Pratt but it was Sam
Worthington who was reportedly living in
his car at the time of auditioning that
got the part and while he and co-stars
like Zoe Saldana and Sigourney Weaver
really are great let's be honest the
main reason people pay the money to see
this and now it's sequel that arrived 13
years later in theaters is because of
its oscar-winning visual effects
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
highest audience score with 500 000
ratings The Dark Knight this certified
fresh film has managed to keep a 94
audience score with over 500 000
audience ratings since it was released
in 2008 and I am so serious for those of
you asking why so serious and that
success is in large part due to the
insanely iconic performance from Heath
Ledger who owned every scene he was in
like nobody ever had or really has since
and here's some proof so
I stick around
and do this
to myself
you know what
she can't stand the sight of me
she leaves
now I see the funny side
now I'm always smiling
little fight now
I like that
so good I mean he won a best supporting
actor Oscar posthumously for his
performance as the film picked up a
total of eight Academy Award nominations
to go along with over a billion dollars
earned at the box office and has further
proof that this one transcends the genre
it was just the second comic book movie
to be added to the National film
registry after 1978's Superman
highest Tomato Meter score with at least
500 reviews Black Panther
and finally at the top of our list is
the highest Tomato Meter score with at
least 500 reviews coming in at a
certified fresh 96 in other words that
is a lot of people in agreement on
something when does that happen Chadwick
Boseman first appeared as Black Panther
in Captain America Civil War before
officially arriving on the scene with
this film in 2018. in this movie he's
challenged by killmonger played by
Michael B Jordan who wants to kick off a
global Revolution and kick a few other
things too
oh
my
[Music]
this was the 18th movie in the MCU and
the first Marvel Studios film with a
black director and Ryan coogler it also
received eight Oscar nominations
including the first best picture nom for
a superhero film and the first Oscar
wins for the MCU black panther permeated
pop culture it was the first ever
representation of an African superhero
in film and to quote Time Magazine the
legacy of its release was seminal for
black Americans wakanda truly is and
always will be forever
all right Amigos that is it the top
spots of some of our biggest and best
rt25 categories go check out more at our
rt25 page on rottentomatoes.com and
thanks for checking out today's list
until next time I am your host Naz Perez
thanks for coming to the party and we'll
see you back here for more Rotten
Tomatoes countdown
[Music]